okay let's continue uh who do we want to
speak to next oh i don't know there's
just so many possibilities here
how about a josh from rhode island rhode
island not a state heavily represented
during live calls josh
uh can you hear me yes i can hell nice
speaking with you
um my question has to do with uh
unemployment
so uh recently i saw that uh they
changed unemployment where you have to
be uh looking for a job again like you
have to be
actively doing that yes and i was
wondering because i hear all the time
people uh they'll say that oh everyone
just wants to be on unemployment
and then when i say that now they have
to be looking for a job i hear
you know people can just uh they just
apply to like i think it's like three
jobs a week
and then don't do anything else and then
just collect their check so i kind of
my question is kind of in two parts
first is
people i hear that a lot but it's
actually that easy to just like
apply to a few places and then get money
without having to do anything
and part two are people actually doing
that because
uh from conservatives i hear all the
time that like people don't want to work
and they'll just you know
apply to a job just to get unemployment
and i one note that's actually a thing
that happens
so first of all in order to initially
qualify for unemployment you actually
have to be unemployed so in normal
circumstances you have to have
lost a job but not been fired for cause
right
and so first so just to qualify for
unemployment
some some uh barriers have to be some
threshold has to be met
is it as simple as applying to a few
jobs to continue receiving unemployment
it basically is yeah and it depends on
the state like for example
when i was in college i used to work for
the now defunct circuit city and when
they
switched from commission to hourly for
salespeople they laid off the top sales
people one of which i was
and so i got to collect unemployment
because my my position was eliminated
i had to go on and say i'm looking for a
job
i wasn't asked where did i apply it was
just have you been looking for a job
yes i have and then i would get the
money that system may have changed the
systems are different
in each state that is something that you
can do you apply for a few jobs
and then you continue collecting
unemployment i am not worried about this
and i've made a couple of clips
explaining why
but fundamentally enhanced unemployment
ends in september
you are not allowed to be on
unemployment an indefinite amount of
time
many people many many people in the fall
are going to get to the end
of unemployment and at that point they
are going to stop receiving the benefits
so um they are either going to have to
figure out how to pay for their expenses
without making any money
or they're going to have to go and get
themselves a job so any any social
insurance program will have some free
riders or people who just do the minimum
in order to keep
collecting the unemployment as long as
the system big picture
is working and unemployment and enhanced
unemployment
saved so many people during the pandemic
i don't worry about a few free riders
they're going to lose their benefits
relatively soon anyway the benefits
don't last forever
all right thank you so just if a
conservative is uh
saying that like you know unemployment
is just keeping people lazy and keeping
them off from working just like
just like mention the benefits and say
that like it's not actually as
you know reliable uh to like live off of
those conservatives think it is
yeah and there is no evidence that most
people want to earn what you earn on
unemployment and don't work
we have a really rare situation right
now because of the pandemic
and the enhanced unemployment but
generally speaking people want to work
generally speaking you make more working
than on
state unemployment now we have a again
we have an enhanced unemployment
and um there are some people who would
be satisfied just making unemployment
and and not working but it's very few
many people get meaning from work people
get a connection to other people most
people want to work
period all right thank you very much
this is actually my first time trying to
call in so it means a lot to be able to
speak with you
so beautiful for all the content thanks
for the call appreciate it thank you
very much
for the longest time i was having
trouble finding snacks
that are healthy but actually taste
great and fill me up and satisfy
a craving and that's why it's great that
i stumbled upon
monk pack and we asked them to be one of
our sponsors
monk pack keto nut and seed bars are
delicious
snacks that have one gram of sugar or
less
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just 150 calories perfect for a
keto or low carb diet or anybody who
like me
just prefers to eat a low sugar diet i
love the monk pack
keto nut and seed bars because it's
really just a great balance of sweet and
salty
soft and chewy but with a nice crunch
from the nuts and seeds
flavors include caramel or caramel
you tell me sea salt sea salt dark
chocolate and peanut butter dark
chocolate that's my favorite
they'll give you all of your money back
if you don't love it go to monkpack.com
the link is down below
and they'll give you 20 off any of their
products when you use coupon code pacman